[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace un par de años participe de un
intercambio educativo y cultural fue una
experiencia súper interesante otro país
nuevos amigos y tratando de conocer
nuevas personas comencé una conversación
con alguien y una de las preguntas
clásicas
a donde aprendiste español porque ese
español era muy bueno y para mi sorpresa
la respuesta no fue algo que yo estaba
esperando porque él me dijo lo aprendí
por mí mismo con mis amigos con la
televisión
a esa edad para mí era complicado
entender cómo puede aprender uno algo
por sí mismo porque yo pensaba que
aprender se centraba en el colegio en la
clase con el profesor los libros y los
compañeros me parecía algo un poco raro
tiempo después hablando con este amigo
él me había contado que terminó la
universidad que consiguió el trabajo de
sus sueños pero que lo hizo justamente
porque tenía algo especial un
diferenciador y éste era que sabía
español y que había aprendido muchas
otras cosas por sí mismo increíble
me puse a pensar un poco sobre esto y
decía porque no había aprendido inglés
hace un par de años porque no había
aprendido otras materias que me
interesaban y si quería echar la culpa a
alguien más también decía por qué no me
ayudaban a aprender por mi cuenta
a veces pensaba no sé si a ustedes les
pasa todo siempre renegamos contra el
hecho de que nos preguntan cosas en el
examen que no nos han enseñado que no
hemos aprendido verdad o por dios justo
lo que no me habían enseñado
pero ahora que lo veo desde otro punto
de vista creo que a veces eso es para
motivarte a que tú empiezas a aprender
algo por tu propia cuenta y por tu
propia curiosidad
una alerta spoiler sobre la vida real
en la vida real uno tiene que aprender
mucho frecuentemente y muchas veces uno
tiene que aprender por su propia cuenta
si es medio complicado cuesta pero te
ayuda a sobrevivir
recuerdo en mi primer trabajo todo nuevo
genial increíble entendía lo que me
pedían que lo que me pedían para hacer
pero como lo hago o por dios o tengo que
empezar a aprender por mi cuenta y fue
de esa forma que logré sobrevivir y
estoy a caballo
hablando un poco del trabajo
pensemos en el siglo 21 todo va muy
rápido
la tecnología avanza todo todo va muy
depende mucho de nosotros empezar hoy
verdad imagínense hace cinco años no
habían trabajos que hoy existen uno
tiene que estar realmente preparado
es algo que no es simple en realidad
aprender o aprender por uno mismo pero
créanme vale la pena y vale la vida
y sobre todo es algo que es parte de
nosotros pues sí es parte del ser humano
es parte de nuestra naturaleza el poder
aprender tal vez recuerda cuando éramos
niños pequeños y te ponías a jugar un
ejemplo te pones a jugar y te dicen
mira y aprende pues uno se ponía segundo
se ponía atento aprendía para poder
hacer ganar al equipo verdad
ahora pensemos también ya un poco más de
jóvenes cuando uno empieza a aprender a
jugar uno el monopolio uno debe
sobrevivir para sobrevivir debe aprender
y si se dan cuenta con poca o ninguna
instrucción uno puede aprender
o yendo un poco más digital quienes
utilizan facebook instagram
como aprendieron a etiquetar a las
personas
si lo piensan un poco fue algo que
pudimos aprender en el camino verdad
quiero contarles de dos chicos de
quienes muchas personas no daban crédito
de que pudieran hacer algo en especial
pero ellos tenían un sueño y debido a
los recursos a la falta de todo lo que
de todo es en ese momento
ellos para cumplir su sueño tuvieron que
aprender y aprender mucho por su cuenta
estudiaron averiguaron aprendieron mucho
sobre la aviación y un día pudieron
volar
qué increíble los hermanos wright
por otro lado también quisiera contarles
sobre walt disney
quien aprendió por sí mismo a dibujar
revolucionó los cuentos de hadas las
caricaturas porque él tenía ese sueño
que quería cumplir
como lo veis nos conviene verdad que
creen
aparte tiene varios beneficios quiero
contarles un poco eso aprender y
aprender por uno mismo te permite ser
independiente te permite tener carisma y
es bueno para la salud
porque independiente imagínense estamos
en un viaje en europa en asia vemos algo
nuevo que nos llama la atención y
queremos aprender sobre eso tenemos que
volver a bolivia y empezar a leer los
libros y todo pues no somos
independientes podemos empezar a
aprender en ese mismo momento
también aprender te da carisma
se imaginan hace un par de años yo era
una niña muy callada que hablaba muy
poco y en el proceso de aprender con
todas esas experiencias y empezar a
aprender por mí misma me ha logrado me
ha permitido realizar varios sueños y
que hoy también esté para aquí
y como les había comentado aprender
también les permite tener buena salud
porque tal vez no suene importante en
estos momentos pero ayuda al cerebro es
saludable y en un par de años lo van a
agradecer
estamos convencidos cómo podemos
aprender cómo podemos aprender por
nosotros mismos
quiero contarles un par de cosas que
empezaba a hacer por ejemplo
siempre puedo encontrar esta necesidad
esta razón que seguramente algunos no
tienen necesito aprender inglés necesito
aprender esto pero también puede ser que
ese motivo sea la curiosidad o la pasión
quien alguna vez ha tenido curiosidad
por saber a patinar o yo he tenido la
curiosidad de aprender chino mandarín y
puedo hacerlo puede aprender
también por pasión por pasión piense en
yo tengo la pasión por la música y la
tecnología puedo empezar a aprender hoy
nuevas canciones para tocarlo en el
piano
curiosidad pasión necesidad cuál es la
razón que les motiva hoy a aprender
también es interesante que cuando uno va
a empezar a aprender por sí mismo pueda
descubrir cuál es la forma en la que
mejor aprende
te gusta aprender leyendo te gusta
aprender viendo vídeos te gusta aprender
con tus amigos
eso es muy bueno es parte de ti mismo te
permite conocer temas y te permite
también aprender muchas cosas nuevas
creo que sí estamos convencidos todos
verdad
algo importante para empezar a aprender
también los recursos que tenemos a
nuestra mano hay más de 100 200 cursos
por internet que uno puede tomar de
cualquier cosa y quién tiene algún
dispositivo inteligente un celular algo
si muy bien tenemos la herramienta y no
dejen que el dispositivo sea más
inteligente que ustedes verdad
para terminar
quería que pensemos en esto de empezar a
aprender hoy porque a veces uno se pone
la meta de ok en enero voy a decir que
voy a aprender esto y lo voy a lograr
por fin el próximo año
pero a veces el problema es que llega a
febrero no he empezado nada y digo o
rayos voy a empezar el próximo año pero
no créanme es buena empezar un día a la
vez y estoy segura que el tour del 2020
te lo va a agradecer y 2020 porque
porque en dos años todo puede pasar la
tecnología va muy rápido el mundo cambia
empieza hoy y quiero que un poco cada
uno me cuente sobre aquello que empezó a
aprender y el trabajo soñado que por fin
lo ha conseguido del proyecto que por
fin ha logrado realizar porque empezó a
aprender y algo extra aprendió por sí
mismo
[Aplausos]